Yeah.
You were one of the,
you mean you,
you were one of the people that I cite all the time for.
Why that stupid reason that the 12 to six elbow,
you're the one that explained it to me.
I couldn't,
I couldn't believe what you're telling me was true at the reason 12 to six
elbows were illegal.
Well,
just tell the story.
Uh,
the truth of the stories back.
There's so many stories about rules and how they came about and you know,
there's guys claiming things and it's like,
really?
Okay,
I have paperwork that shows how the war,
how things came out and at what time it was.
And I still have my computers that I have things written on that we went over
stuff.
But you have computers from the 90s,
dude,
I still have no,
I've got floppy disk.
No,
you don't swear to God.
He'd do.
Unbelievable.
How much can a floppy,
this hold not even like a magnet,
right?
Nothing holds a couple of pages of a document.
But you remember when the floppy disk went away,
everybody panicked.
Like,
what are you doing?
You're fucking taken away.
The floppy disk.
That's how rage is.
What are you going to put stuff on that?
When Matt got rid of the floppy disk,
I remember people like these guys are assholes,
what are they thinking?
But anyways,
when,
when the unified rules,
you know,
what happened was everyone looks at the UFC and says,
oh well you know,
when the UFC went to the first show that was done in New Jersey was the IFC Paul
Smith's show.
It was done in September,
I want to say of 1999 okay.
And the UFC went there in November of 1999 and,
and yet you have to go back and understand the history of what was going on.
And you know,
this is where I have my issues with people that try to change history and
rewrite things.
And what was going on was seven to 400 payment group at the time owned the UFC.
That's who you were working,
Bob Meyrowitz Meyrowitz and Mclaren Campbell.
Mclaren was long gone,
you know,
and I love I then by 99 oh my God,
yes.
You know,
and you talked to the day when I came around in [inaudible] 97 yeah.
Well I think he hired you.
Yeah.
And you know,
he did some stuff and he comes up with a,
you know,
on the cocreator the UFC.
You know what,
let me just ask one question.
If you're the cocreator,
how come you never owned one bit of it doesn't make sense.
Doesn't out Campbell Mclaren.
Yes.
Dare you.
You know what?
I'm tired of.
Why lie he did things and I will,
I will absolutely give him credit for what he did because he was the reason that
it actually made it to pay per view because art Davey had gone to everyone.
Prime ticket at the time was a paper view provider because the paper view world
back then was about 15 million in the u s it's not like it is now.
You know,
you,
you were limited,
but you know,
prime ticket was one,
HBO was another and he had gone to all those and they all turn,
no,
no.
And there was this one company,
semaphore entertainment group out of New York that did rock and roll shows and
they did one sporting event.
It was Martina Navratilova against Jimmy Connors and tennis.
Oh Wow.
You make a remake of the Billie Jean King Bobby Riggs thing.
Wow,
I remember that.
Uh Huh.
That's crazy.
That was them.
I didn't know that was [inaudible].
That was the only sporting thing they'd ever done before the UFC.
But they were,
they were looking for something that they could rerun and,
and make happen again and again.
And Campbell looked at what art brought to him and said,
I think this could be that thing.
And Horry and came up with the idea Horian Gracie,
negative,
not true.
He says he came up with the idea of,
are you saying you calling out Horian Gracie?
He not calling
big John doesn't fuck around.
Look it whore.
Horry Horry and had,
you know his thing and I love,
you know what,
I fell in love with what they did.
That's how I got involved.
Right.
But horian are,
Davey went to Horian because he needed validity.
He needed somebody to give actual value and some credence to what he was trying
to do because he went to Horian off of,
uh,
there was an article in Playboy magazine bad,
you know,
and it was about Horian and you know,
at this guy,
this family that would fight anybody.
And you know,
Chad was a bad article that would called back.
That was the actual title B,
a d across two pages bad.
Ah,
was the,
I remember we had the article,
I don't remember that part about it,
but it was,
it was basically they were offering like a lot of money to fight anybody,
right.
Well,
it was the whole thing of the hundred thousand dollars,
but he didn't have $100,000,
you know,
and so it was,
well,
if you bring $100,000,
I'll put up a hundred.
No one's bringing $100,000.
So just more like a publicity stunt.
Yeah,
they did.
Obviously they had the Gracie challenge before that and they did all the Gracie
in action tapes that we had all seen.
Yup.
And he'd see all these karate masters it down,
strangled,
you know,
and that was,
that was the thing that I loved the fact when,
you know,
I can go through the whole thing of how I met Horian but when I met him there
was never anything about,
well you know,
we,
we would do this and that situation but we can't do that cause will hurt you or
something like that was what happened in a lot of martial arts all,
well we can't do that because that would really,
that will hurt you,
that will kill you.
And he was like,
let's do it right every time.
And that's what I fell in love with.
It's like,
hey,
they're not phony.
They're real.
Right.
The first time I ever did anything with them all hoists Gracie arm barred me and
I went,
how did you do that?
And I just fell in love with it.
A lot of people said that about Hoists Gracie,
how?
Yeah.
Those early days of the UFC was,
boy,
I mean you want to talk about,
I mean he really played it out perfectly because it really was the best version
of explaining Jujitsu.
Like did how,
how do you show the effectiveness?
Did you just say,
well here's what you do.
You'll lock some dudes in a cage with no rules,
guides bigger than him and he's wearing his geeky.
So he looks,
he's the only one that looks like,
like what we think of as a martial artist,
right?
And you get these guys,
everyone else looks like big old street thugs.
The jacked up on steroids.
They're giant and they're running after him.
And we always would think of like Bruce Lee and these martial artists who it
technique over size and they would beat all these people,
but in the real world,
that shit didn't work.
Nope.
Just didn't work.
Bigger guys always fucked you up.
They were heavier.
You hit him.
It didn't work.
It bounced off of them.
That got you on the ground.
They punched your face in.
But all of a sudden there was this little guy who wasn't little,
but you know,
it was 175 pounds in comparison to the rest of the people.
He was fairly small and he's tapping guys at triangles off his back and arm bar
and people and,
and everybody with greatest,
greatest infomercial ever.
It was the greatest.
Exactly.
Got me on board.
I mean to me and everybody else,
man,
all these people that like me came from a striking background.
I was like Holy Shit.
And that's like,
this is crazy.
That's where I look at.
Horian was brilliant because he listened to what art said and goes and look at
art.
So whose idea was it?
It was art.
It was arts idea to have a bunch of guys fight.
Absolutely.
100% well how much did art,
how much of the art owner that he owned a,
I want to say basically 25% 20 when they sold it to,
cause they had [inaudible] he got a piece of that.
Oh well no,
he was,
he was gone.
Gone before that.
You've got to figure when there was two there was wow promotions and wild
promotions came from war of the worlds because art had named the whole
competition or the world.
Ah,
and then Semafore entertainment group changed it to the ultimate fighter.
I vaguely remember that whole thing.
Guy Named Michael Abrams is the one that named it.
So it when,
when art had with Horry on,
he gave Horian 25% he had 25% and Bob Myerwitz own 50% because of putting it on
paper view.
Ah,
so you had while promotions owning 50% seven or 400 tamer group owning 50% and
actually wow.
Owned a little bit less because they had brought together investors and they
were trying to get $250,000 and they got somewhere around 115,000 hundred
$12,000 of investment that they put up cause that was going to be part of the
money for the people that we're competing in it.
It's crazy.
When you think about what it is now,
this is where we're talking about 1993 what new sport can you think of other
than MMA from 1993 that's now a huge global force.
I mean,
it is something that everybody talks about globally.
Nothing.